Oh
[Music]
so we have a constant conversation in
society about the role of technology in
the world right mankind has this
capacity to extend his agency into these
scaffoldings into these tools that are
beyond his biological skin tissue we
extend our mind we're out into the world
the Mars rover right now
Oh crawls the surface of Mars extending
our optic nerve into space that is what
we do with our tools and increasingly
these tools are giving us transformation
disruption they're giving us new
construction kits for our reality you
know mark Pesce has a great line he says
that advances in emerging biotechnology
which gives us the power to harness the
software of life and in emerging
technologies of nanotech which allow us
to pattern the physical atoms of the
physical world increasingly are making
the world linguistically pliable right
DNA is code the material science of
nanotech allows us to turn this into
something that can be rendered at the
speed of thought this notion of reality
of the world becoming linguistically
pliable tells us that mind okay that
that agency that sentience has
overpowered the biosphere the mind
sphere the new Oh sphere is now a force
of geological impact consider that the
next time you're sitting at dinner
talking to somebody about the role
of Technology I mean it's really like
it's the bursting forth of the new
agency a new agent of evolution we are
evolution evolving its own involve
ability right who knows where we're
gonna go
you
[Music]